Mjolnir
you're back
excuse me there's a maniac who seeks to end
us all we have to stop him are you packed
yes i hand grenade no it's a portable speaker
on july 8 another classic thor adventure and flip
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him mean eventually grape
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
thor love and thunder trailer video there's a
whole bunch of new footage we'll break it
all down because thor love and thunder is
also coming out in theaters really soon we're
doing a giveaway for imax tickets all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just post
all your theories about the movie on the video
also name a giveaway winner later during this
video too i know a lot of you are asking about
zeus hercules is thor more powerful in this
movie is odin more powerful than zeus like
what are the power levels of all these different
god characters the funny connection between thor
and hercules is that they can actually increase
their power levels through cosmic trials they
kind of did that recently with the hercules
character in a big arc called the chaos war
but the way they play the hercules character
in the comics his personality is very similar
to thor's personality but we've never seen
him in the marvel movies before but the fact
that they're doing zeus and it seems like gore is
gonna kill him off during the course of the movie
just provides this really easy in for an arc for
a hercules character in the mcu so you can post
all your theories about what they might do with
hercules in a future mcu arc but just starting at
the beginning the new clip starts with thor vs
gore's minions we've learned a little bit more
about where he's coming from in the movie it's
a little bit different from the comics through
the shadow realm how do you know the atmosphere
there has a darkness like no other this is if
color feels to trade it's unmistakable there was
a separate clip where thor talks about the shadow
realm which is like an alternate dimension made
up of pure shadows where he says color literally
fears to tread which sort of connects with some
of the trailer footage too where they're all
fighting later in the movie and you see the only
color is coming off the god tier weapons or the
gods themselves like thor like thor is giving off
color because it's his god tier energy and in the
background you can see these black creatures sort
of writhing like their minions from this alternate
dimension that gore has been using also kind of
confirming that's where the power of the necro
sword comes from too like he gets it from the
shadow realm but then he gets the second costume
upgrade like you can see him change his appearance
using his power where he slams stormbreaker down
that's a bit of a magic enchantment if it wasn't
clear thor can also wield magic the same way that
odin did the same way that loki did he's just much
less learned in magic than loki so like loki just
knows a bunch of spells that he doesn't know and
he also pretends to be a little bit dumber than he
actually is valkyrie comes to get him they have
all those funny scenes with the goats there's
also a bit of an easter egg we learned about that
during guardians of the galaxy 3. they're having
a holiday special later this year james gunn
confirmed that the goats come back during the
holiday special like there's some funny moments
with the guardians of the galaxy having to deal
with the goats like korg makes all the jokes
about how they just do nothing but scream and
cause trouble so he comes back to new asgard gorge
minions attack from the shadow realm you see them
fighting all these characters all over the place
everything is going crazy and he sees that mjolnir
has come back for some reason trying to call
it to himself but not being able to and they
have the big reveal of jane foster calling it to
her like it destroys one of these shadow minions
then comes to her hand he sees her for the first
time doesn't know that it's jane foster right away
that's why you hear him saying excuse me excuse me
like he's getting ready to run up and ask her what
the hell is going on but then she uses mjolnir's
new power that is gained as it's reformed like
she has this area of effect attack where the
hammer basically breaks into a bunch of pieces
and then because one of the hammers trademark
abilities is coming back when someone calls it
back to them the pieces come back and reform to
the regular hammer because of the way the trailer
footage plays out presumably thor upgrades again
to his battle armor like the blue gold armor with
the full helmet they finish off the rest of these
minions and then he runs up to jane foster's store
asking what the hell is going on and she takes the
helmet off and he realizes that it is jane foster
side note 2 in the background of this shot you can
see a tavern named the black raven obviously named
after odin's ravens and in the comics those aren't
actual ravens but he uses those as devices to just
monitor what's going around the different nine
realms they're probably jokes like this in the
building names all over new asgard there are a lot
of funny moments in the other clips that they just
released where thor keeps trying to call mjolnir
back to himself like come here come to daddy like
he calls the hammer all kinds of funny things like
first he talks to it like it's a dog like hear me
on here whistling to it like you would to a pet
and they have the funny moment with stormbreaker
showing up like oh yes i totally meant to call you
stormbreaker i wasn't trying to call my old hammer
if it weren't clear stormbreaker isn't meant to
be sentient in the movies mjolnir does have a
consciousness in the comics though but i think
the way they played it in the movies the hammer
is not alive and i think during this movie one
of the reasons why he can't pick it up or call
it to himself is all about gore's storyline with
believing that the gods are unworthy and don't
care about their subjects in thor at least at
the beginning of the movie not really knowing
what his purpose is and having this existential
crisis like he hasn't literally become unworthy
he just kind of confused about his true purpose
and the confusion is what's causing him to not
be able to pick up mjolnir even though they don't
have footage of it in the trailer here too jamie
alexander's sif is back she was at the premiere
talking about coming back like yay siff is back
angie came back during the loki series for that
big cameo scene it was really funny obviously like
a slightly different iteration of the character
because of the way they played it she also came
back to voice her character during the what if
series because there was an episode that had the
warriors three so sif was in one of the episodes
but the way that jamie alexander talked about it
sif is back for good like she will survive the end
of this movie and show up in future thor or new
asgard related projects or anything that involves
the character so a lot of you asking what's she
doing in the movie and where was she during thor
ragnarok avengers infinity war avengers end game
did sif get snapped where has she been this whole
time the funny story about why sif is still alive
is actually a bit of a coincidence because when
taiko battiti was making thor ragnarok there was
a scene where hella comes back to new asgard and
what was going to happen is they were gonna kill
off the entire warriors three like hello was gonna
mow through them to show you how badass she was
so originally taika watiti was gonna kill off
jamie alexander's sif character during that
scene like she was gonna be part of that fighting
hella and she was gonna die but when they were
actually shooting the movie jamie alexander had
a schedule conflict because she was working on a
different tv show and she just physically could
not get herself to set to film those scenes
so that's how sifs survived the events of thor
ragnarok in regardless of whether or not you
think she got snapped she was not in that giant
scene of all the avengers sort of flying across
frame fighting thanos's army during the final
battle and i think the reason for that is just
because they felt like there were too many people
like they tried to include as many characters as
possible like there were a lot of people that were
not in that scene that could have been so i think
the idea during thor love and thunder is that
when she comes back they'll just say that she was
off doing other things when all that was going
down like she was busy with other problems and
i was just talking about kit harrington's black
knight because they just announced this big game
of thrones jon snow sequel series he's still the
black knight in the mcu but the really cool thing
about her winged horse aragorn is that winged
horse was actually given to her at least in the
comics by dane whitman's black knight obviously in
the mcu the back story is a little bit different
like she has no interaction with the black knight
character that we know of and it sounds like odin
just created all these winged horses and gave them
to his valkyrie core they have that funny scene
with zeus at the godhead again the shot of all the
other gods in the background there are many many
gods in there from every single culture i know a
lot of you are asking how do they exist who are
all the gods what are they doing during the movie
is this just a glorified kill box scene to set up
gore the god butcher coming up and killing a lot
of these why didn't they help out with thanos
during avengers infinity war in avengers end
game that there is probably most of the reason
why gore is going around killing all these gods
we lost half the universe and you did nothing
and a lot of times the way they explain the power
of most gods is that they just have the abilities
and the powers that their followers believe that
they have like the power of their belief brings
them into creation but gods themselves can also
have biological children there's a big storyline
during the gore comics where he goes back in time
to try and kill like the original elder god to get
the most amount of power from gods they could
possibly get i don't think they're going to do
that in the movie exactly but the way that the
comics explain is that with each new generation
of gods like their children their children's
children and so on and so forth the god tier
cosmic power that gets passed along gets diluted
over time so billions and billions of years later
in present day you have all these different
gods that have come from just a few elder gods
and their powers become so deluded now that gore
the god butcher the necro sword is powerful enough
to go around killing them they actually referenced
the elder gods during doctor strange multiverse of
madness cathode the god of chaos is one of the
elder gods he once ago the first demon to thorn
carved his dark magic into this tomb now he's not
part of the original group of elder gods he's just
part of one of the oldest groups of gods so he
had way more power than the gods that you see
today the whole story behind what happened to
those really old elder gods is actually tied up
in the creation of omnipotent city like billions
of years ago all these gods had their own version
of a god tier avengers endgame event where they
all fought war with each other bunch of people
died off reality was almost destroyed eventually
the ones that were left alive called to truce
and to mark the truce they created omnipotent
city which was meant to be a city of fellowship
amongst all the gods so that's why in present day
you see all these different gods here as part of
the godhead meeting talking about what to do about
gore the god butcher probably right before he
shows up to kill zeus just explain who the most
powerful god is here in this room like thor can
become more powerful but he has to go through a
bunch of cosmic trials and that happens during the
gore comics it also happens during the rune king
thor comics which is sort of like a completely
separate thing like just because you're a god
doesn't mean you're locked at a certain power
level gods can become more powerful either through
the artifacts that they wield or the cosmic trials
that they go through but like for instance in
the comics odin is meant to be way more powerful
than zeus because of the odin force but the movies
seem like they're trying to play that a slightly
different way like zeus is supposed to be super
op like he flicks too hard and that whole scene
is supposed to be ridiculous and funny just to set
up how badass gore is with the necro sword when
he comes in and just completely rolls over zeus
it'll be fun to see how many easter eggs for the
gore storyline they included in the comics i know
there's a lot of questions people have like are
they gonna do anything with null the necrosaur the
all black i'm not expecting a ton of null stuff in
this movie i think it'll be mostly just gore and
mighty thor storyline stuff but if you spotted
any other easter eggs in the trailer that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments and i do have a couple more doctor
strange two deleted scene videos that i'll post
in the next couple of days so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
those congratulations code khalil you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel
or my website so i can get your contact details
everyone click here to learn about the really cool
doctor doom easter egg and deleted scenes during
doctor strange 2 and click here for my thor love
and thunder celestials trailer video and easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!